call of duty black ops cold war has two
major endings and even a sub ending
let's break them down and watch how each
of these play out this goes without
saying but i'm gonna say it anyway
major spoilers ahead these are the
endings to black ops cold war
you've been warned in the final hours of
the game it's revealed that your
character bell has been brainwashed
at this point you're unsure of where
your loyalties lie and when you awaken
you can decide to lie to adler about
perseus's location
or tell him the truth and help america
by stopping a massive
nuclear attack solovetsky
sims get washington on the line if you
tell the truth adler and the team take
your word for it and prepare to capture
perseus
you woods mason and adler set out to the
solovetsky islands in the ussr where the
launch site is
you arrive and take out the anti-air
guns so that the u.s can bomb the site
and stop the launch
you save the world and prevent this cold
war from going hot
although you don't capture perseus this
ending is canon
we did it this is a message to perseus
and those that'll follow him
we don't just sit back and hope for the
best
we'll make the best happen this is how
wars are won bell
they did it mr president they stopped
the nukes
thank god and the cia did they get
perseus
no sir his whereabouts are unknown and a
russian response
nothing yet we're seeing signs of
confusion it's
possible this was all a rogue operation
perseus may
not have been following orders from
moscow well i'll be damned
maybe we have something in common after
all
after a quick summary of the story you
get one last cut scene
arctic air
clears the head doesn't it
bell you made two extraordinary
sacrifices to stop perseus
one was without your knowledge the other
you made that decision in your own
accord
[Music]
i just want you to know that this little
thing that's happened with you and me
it was always for the greater good
your goddamn hero you know that kid
heroes have to make sacrifices
that's why when i ask you one more i
hope you understand
it was never personal
so this doesn't end well for belle but
if we go back to your options
lying to adler sets you up for ending
number two you divert the american team
to a soviet base that houses the duga
array
a massive missile defense system this
has nothing to do with the main plan and
only leads the americans to a dead end
adler takes your word for it and
prepares to capture perseus
you made the right choice bill come on
you're still one of us
what they don't know is you have an
option here to communicate with the duga
base
and tell them that the americans are
coming and to prepare for an ambush
the only way to secure this ending is by
unlocking a secret gate in hudson
safehouse
which is the side puzzle earlier in the
game
you sure you're not forgetting something
bill
there's nothing here this can't be the
right place
we didn't see anything on our side
either it's him [ __ ] lied to us
that true bell you pull us out to the
middle and know where russia's so
perseus can detonate those nukes
all your speech combat ready for a
little retribution
this is it your friend went through here
he is not far
come out and play you are running out of
time
and space
the cat becomes the mouse
glad to see you still care
mind giving me a light
i'd offer you sick
that street dog should have been put
down long ago
you remember my face don't you
solovetsky stand by for the detonation
order
i think you deserve this moment
i wish we could return to solovetsky to
watch it all unfold
but that chapter is closed now we begin
the next one together
you did well
and to think after all this time
they still believe i'm perseus
as if perseus could ever be an
individual working alone
so american
ah we'll need a new home now
the central committee will be more
surprised than the cia
even if we made the best choice for the
future of our homeland
yet for humanity
their eyes will be as clouded as ours
once were
come there is still much to be done
the launch goes according to plan and
back in the united states
hudson's base is burned to the ground to
remove america's involvement in this
disaster
my god how many green-like nukes did he
detonate
all of them mr president does anyone
know the bombs were ours
materials related to operation green
light were anonymously released an hour
ago
presumably by perseus calls are
beginning to come in from across the
globe
that son of a [ __ ] you and vice
president bush are to be moved to secure
locations immediately
i want any business related to this
thing erased forever
everything can you make that happen
of course it's already begun
we will watch europe burn
we will watch the empire of the united
states collapse under its own weight
a world with two superpowers will become
a world with one
the soviet union
and if the leaders of this new world
order squander the opportunity
we have provided them
then they too will be replaced and
lastly if you lie to adler but don't
call for an ambush in duga
you get another result seen here
there's nothing here this can't be the
right place
we didn't see anything on our side
either it's him [ __ ] lied to us
that true bell you pull us out to the
middle and know where russia's so
perseus can detonate those
nukes
kind of [ __ ] up logic is that
what a waste you actually could have
done something with yourself kid
those nukes were for defense not offense
you don't recognize the difference
i'd let you walk back to perseus but i
think i'll spare you the regret instead
apparently we didn't do a good enough
job
time's up again
i guess i'll finish this job
[ __ ] if i care leave it for perseus to
find
get hudson on the horn we got to warn
the president
all in all we're happy to see that cold
war has a few options for players to try
out
let us know what ending you're choosing
and be on the lookout for more call of
duty coverage
right here on gamespot
[Music]
you